لما الغزاه هجموا على مصر
قام لهم السلطان حامد وقال لهم
والله ما تدخلوا اللي على جثتي
وقع تنوع ليس فقط من ناحيه الافكار بل
كمان من ناحيه طبيعه هذه الامل في
المنافسه ليست فقط ما بين الدراما الشعبيه
والرومانسيه والاجتماعيه والكوميديه
والبطوليه كالمعتاد بل ايضا التاريخيه
والدينيه واللي اشتقنا لها جدا كمشاهدين
هي المسلسلات الدينيه لها جمهور كبير لكن
ليه ان هو قلل انتاج بتاعها لان الانتاج
خرج من انتاج اتحاد الدول اذاعه
التليفزيون او انتاج الدوله وراح لمنتج
الطاقه فانتم حلفائك
الفرنساويين هترسموا الخريطه الجديده بس
الظاهر
ما بينه التقسيم هذا العام في عده اعمال
تصنف تاريخيه مثلا سر الباتع اهم تفاصيله
بعد لكن طبعا لا زالت هناك الكثير من
المفاجات بشانه للمخرج خالد يوسف واللي
تدور احداثه ما بين زمنين هم العسل الحالي
وعصر الحمله الفرنسيه على مصر عام
1798 كمان مسلسل العربجي بطوله باسم ياخور
واللي تدور احداثه ما بين
1830 ميلادي وايضا مسلسل الذنب بطوله تيم
حسن وليتناول حقبه مهمه في تاريخ لبنان
وسوريا حول عام 1900 ميلادي وقبل الحرب
العالميه الاولى ايضا مسلسل رساله الامام
بطوله خالد النبوي حيث تناول سيره الامام
الشافعي في ظل متغيرات التي شهدتها مصر
قبل اكثر من الف عام
وكنت اظنها لا تفرج
انتاج المسلسل التاريخي وانتاج كبير
الكادر تبعه كبير اماكن التصوير بدا اماكن
كبيره بدها بدها مشاهد خارجيه كتيره بدها
ديكور معين فدائما المنتج بيحسب حساب هذا
الموضوع تكلفه كتير كبيره هل يا ترى حيرد
التكلفه هل حيحقق ارباح الجمهور سعيد
بعوده هذا النوع من الاعمال حيث تفاعل مع
اخبارها ويبحث عن تفاصيلها طوال الوقت
خاصه مسلسل رساله الامام وليتصدر محركات
البحث بحسب احصاءات جوجل
[موسيقى]
انت طول عمرك رح تضلك بعيني صغير
بعمرك ما رح تكون كبير
[موسيقى]